his first start since july 2nd following
his third visit to the engine list this
year
this time it was a right hamstring
strain but very happy to say your ram
truck starting pitcher today is zach
and concurs just guided it through the
infield didn't hit it real hard but he's
on to start the day for the cubs and
here's rizzo here's a stretch by gallon
and the next one is a little ground ball
galloway field third base side fires the
first for the out on the play contreras
gets to second
that was just a little squibbler right
off the end of the bat for an out one to
three went out of the inning now this is
a nice quick early test for that right
hamstring yeah exactly he got up there
very quickly
241 he's belted 21 home runs
quick and a miss went to that changeup
he called it that would
leave him wide open to that pitch and he
bit
his bounce back nicely this is hit deep
to right center field long run for
paving smith
patty gets there
brian gave it a ride but gallon strands
contreras stevax coming up
starting pitcher for the cubs 26 year
old right hander from venezuela
to see the fastball usage you'd like to
see that maybe up towards the 60 percent
mark
and ready to go
and that one line and caught
and javi baez ready for that one now the
batter eduardo escobar
escobar and that one flared and there's
baez
fielding percentage fielding percentage
seven pitch inning and half will reach
base with two outs no score second
inning and the batter is raphael ortega
dotted the fastball and gets the
strikeout scoreless two innings for zach
gallon here at chase
christian last night had a double and a
single in the ball game two for four and
that's a ground ball right side and that
will get through by the diving nico
horner in the right field nice inside
out swing there by christian for the
diamondbacks first hit their first space
runner in this ball game but
uh bobbled the ball he did get the out
at first the runners advancing to second
and third have nick take advantage of it
right here is what they need
all right chopper
baez will get one out
and that gets walker home and the
diamondbacks strike first
you see a 0-1 pitch
and there's a ground ball down to third
oh nice play by eduardo and he gets him
there was a lot of ball showing in the
top of that glove but eduardo is only
goes about five nine or so
used all the hops he could sons would
have been proud of him there he got that
ball and got the out otherwise that's a
hit to start this inning here is
contraris
one-nothing diamondbacks in the third
wilson gets hit by the pitch
he got hit in the left arm he's got a
heavy pad on the arm i don't think it uh
caused any damage
contreras on the move
they're at strike three
and there's your
strike about throw them off the end of
the inning for zach gallon and dalton
varshall
now baez who struck out his first time
leads off the fourth
queen
got him on that cutter slider strikeout
number four for gallon
one way now for chris brian who flied
out deep to right center
well back-to-back strikeouts for gallon
opened up the fourth he's punched out
five can you just imagine what that
looked like big daddy only threw one
pitch anyway so it worked out
nice quick one two three fourth for zach
gallon back from the injured list and
holding a one-nothing lead
all right so pitches by inning
that
bump in the road in the second gave up
the run and through 20 but he's been
pretty efficient otherwise
walker then peralta then van meter one
nothing arizona
a swing and a miss carved up walker
[Applause]
that's hit hard and out there roving in
shallow right corner handles it
sixth ground ball out and now it's van
meter who's all for one
popped in the air and going out bryant
coming on hat and ian squeeze is that
seven straight retired by advert
alzheimer
i think we'll get an idea swinging to
miss he gets horner
and varnish got to throw him out at
first and he does one away that's six
strikeouts now tubby this second time
through the order now he has faced six
hitters and he struck out four of them i
mean i think if you told tory okay
gallon's going to go out there give you
five scoreless he'd be where do i sign
i think you're right
one out here in the fifth inning one
other dieback lead swinging him is he
struck him out and gallon another
strikeout that's seven in the ball game
for zach and two quick cubs out here in
the fifth
here's a shot to center pavon smith on
the run he's got it side retired at
order one two three we head to the
diamondback fifth inning
and now a chance for dalton varshall
gatlin comes out in the on-deck circle
sounded like he broke his bat short
right center they're drifting out there
who's got it brian can't get it it's off
the glove
oh bermuda triangle deal out there chris
bryant the third baseman ranging way
over there with the overshift on
and trying to make a sort of backward
over-the-shoulder catch that's a base
hit for version gallon will take the
at-bat
that one hit on the ground
we get one there back to first and they
get two
and advancing to third base is ahmed
and rojas dunks it into right center
almond is home and it's two nothing
diamondbacks
here's your two out rbi knock
two on and
one out for baez who comes up now
actually
has a go-ahead run of this game
that's drilled center field way back
there and that'll hit the base of the
wall
in the score is contreras rizzo takes a
turn but he'll hang on in the second is
baez it's a rocket double and it's 2-1
and now
it's brian good second and third and one
out
tap the third coming home versio
got him rizzo going on soft contact
escobar came home and varshall applied
the tag two outs they cut down the tying
ronin gallon does not want to come out
little negotiation here
uh he might is he gonna talk him into it
let's see uh sorry zach sorry that
second visit
and the clubs have two men on with two
down
and it's up to patrick wisdom
[Applause]
he got him on the fastball
no way ramirez no way ramirez it's still
2-1
ortega the left-handed hitting center
fielder with two outs in the cub ninth
inning
line and that's a base heading to the
corner that should be extras ortega
sprinting around first on his way to
second and he's in there
and the tying run
in scoring position
robinson torinos by the way does have a
pinch at homer
line and that one off the glove in a
short stop and out of the left ortega
coming around
and we're tied up two two
here is wilson contreras stepping in
contreras drives one of the air down the
line and left a fair ball and it's going
to be a two run home run
right down the line in left
the cubs have taken a 4-2 lead here in
the ninth inning
peralta at first two down cubs lead 4-2
jack swing did he go yes he did ball
game
cubs win
what a win
for the cubs here today and now all
alone in ninth place in big league
history
as he passes jonathan papelbon save
number 369 for craig kimbrell and
appropriately enough
standing next to the hero today wilson
contreras